the Joe Rogan experience Marshalls
trying to say hi to you hey buddy hey
buddy I didn't even notice he got up I'm
sorry he's my best friend
how dare you Martha yeah yeah that that
I forgot where we were sorry you're
talking about
that's exactly my intersectional oh yeah
hi Marshall come here no I knows he
wants to flag you can't play you want to
lay down yeah I just don't want to get
in the way uh um so you were saying that
you realized that everybody has their
problems doesn't matter if you're black
or white yeah I really learned a lot
those women it was run by lesbians they
they like taught me some [ __ ] that stuck
with me my whole life like cluttered
room cluttered mind yeah I loved that
one it was basically like they were very
strict but what happened was I learned
how to be a really crafty drug addict so
I was like well as long as my room is
clean I don't have a problem because I
came I came to LA at 19 or 20 I guess
and this is like 2000 and I started
interning at this website called buddy
head it was like this old music website
and they were all Punk and they had the
number-one gossip site for music in town
at the time and everybody was obsessed
with us with with this website and then
feeling Marshall is a distraction here
he seems like he seems a little restless
buddy come here come here pal come here
he's so cute though I can't bear to kick
him out
[Laughter]
seriously you've been asking for him to
be on the show forever he's just gonna
he'll do the rounds he'll go to you hi
what are you doing in here he'll go to
you who get Pat and me he'll get Pat but
the I just don't want to interrupt the
conversation now a little bit of a
distraction that's fine I'm all over it
I don't want to be yanking you wires out
either hey he's going to Jamie now told
you doing the rounds that's what he does
there's such like love [ __ ] it's a maze
Golden's are love sponges so is my boxer
she'll go sleep from one bed to another
to another she gets all the love well he
doesn't he's not allowed to sleep in
beds yeah but he's uh he's very loved
I've never had a dog like that before
they're just so different than any other
dog I've ever had because it's just he's
just a constant friendly lover mmm no he
never gets annoyed with you it never
wants to go lie down but he's always
happy when you say hi to him yeah just
start talking it's just like your
unconditional yeah that mean it's crazy
those used to be wolves I know them into
this thing I know domesticated
themselves sort of thin they yes like a
mutual thing well initially but you know
there was actually a display going on
right now that I went to last weekend at
the what's that Science Museum in LA
what is it called science thing downtown
yeah it's downtown the one next to the
arena with the football arena I think
it's the California Science Center
whatever it is it's there's a whole
thing on dogs okay it's a whole thing
there's one of them it shows how dogs
became dogs from wolves and the slow
process of their ears starting to droop
and their snout starting in short they
became smaller and I mean every animal
and this is something that they didn't
realize I don't think it's whole like
the last couple of decades for the
longest time they thought that wolves
werewolves and dogs were a mixture of
wild dogs and cannons and all these
different animals and they realized oh
no these are all wolves Wow [ __ ]
Chihuahua is okay I just have such a
hard time believing that it doesn't make
any sense that's like saying a Prius is
a car Accord that can it doesn't make
any sense
yeah that's true though yeah it is true
they found out that somehow another
human being is manipulated you know
through selective breeding they took a
wolf and turned it into like an English
bulldog it's crazy
but I love them well that's yeah she let
him out just let him out cuz he probably
he might have to pee or something like
that and he wants to go talk to this
he's going to the door because he wants
to go get love from everybody else yeah
all the security guys
[ __ ] cutest dog of all time he's so
cute
I've never so good to have around oh
yeah he's like he whenever you feel bad
you just go to him and just he just
gives you love and kisses their presence
is huge for things that are pretty
silent for the most part when my dog is
boarded or whatever it's like what I
feel like there's this like giant
presence that's gone when you know what
it is though it's like emotional candy
like you shouldn't have candy all the
time
and you should have people in your life
yeah right you shouldn't just be one of
those [ __ ] weirdo dog piece yeah [ __ ]
vitamins they just eaten candy like no I
don't go to dog parks because of that oh
it's so true right the dog park scene in
LA as psychotic and there's always
someone or the dog that can't control
yeah that's been me before too when I
was one my one of my dogs one of my pit
bulls was a puppy he was like five
months old maybe six I would open up the
door he would run to find the first dog
you find fight him in the Fiero like I
had never had a dog like that before
yeah I didn't know how to handle it I
didn't know that like he can't this is a
male dog with his balls and he's five
six months old you literally can't bring
her unless you like have them rigorously
trained yeah and it needs to be rigorous
like shot-caller someone yeah and
someone has to show you how to do it
correctly yeah that the dog after scene
two attacks in a dog park I was like
okay no people bring [ __ ] crazy dogs
dog parks yeah and I treat my day I mean
there's some I there's some leniency but
I'm very much like it's a dog I'm not
one of the like let's dress in sweaters
and have a birthday party for like no no
that's it we're not having a birthday
party for my dog party we're not putting
any kind of Halloween costume on this
pet just my kids do all that [ __ ] to
Marshall they do all that [ __ ] to him
you know they dressed him up like a fish
the other day they got him a fish cause
I'm like nah he's a [ __ ] dog with a
crazy he's like I can't move this weird
outfit on
[Applause]